شركة اسرائيلية. هذا الرجل
الامريكي تبرع بحيواناته المنوية
سيول ثمانية اشخاص وسبع شركات
يشتبه في تورطهم في انشطة غير
الاحداث والتطورات فرضت الولايات
المتحدة وكوريا الجنوبية عقوبات
عبر الانترنت وبات ابا لمئة
وسبعة عشر طفلا. وها هو يتفاخر
على كوريا الشمالية على خلفية
تجاربها الصاروخية وطالت عقوبات
الدفاع البريطانية تلغي عقد
تدريب عسكري وتناقش الغاء اخر مع
المتحدة يمضي الاوروبيون اوقاتهم
لمقاومة الضغط الروسي. لكن ماذا
السورية. بشار الاسد يقول ان
تركيا هي من يدعم الارهاب في
بذلك عبر قناة سي ان ان ما بين
المفاوضات والاستنجاد بالولايات
الشمال السوري وتركيا تقول نفس
الحديث. ترسو شوكة الحق برأيكم؟
المقبلة. وذلك حسب ما ذكرت بوابة
بايونير الاخبارية. فكيف سيرد
نووية عدة اماكن تحيط بالصين.
فيالخبثكم العسكري. تركيا تحصل
الاخرى تمضي لتحارب كل ما هو
صيني حيث اعلنت واشنطن عن وجود
تحت الماء بغواصتها وهذا الامر
في بالغ الاهمية والهدف منه جمع
هو رسالة امريكية للخصوم والصين
هي ابرز خصومها. واشنطن تتسلل
وواحد وعشرين. ومن المانيا الى
المغرب حيث كشفت التقارير
النووي وذلك من خلال حمل صواريخ
باليستية عابرة للقارات ذات رؤوس
العسكري. فما هو الهدف برأيكم?
لنعد الى خصوم الصين وابرز
العمليات التركية? يتسائل
السوريون. ويقولون ان واشنطن مخز
الخط الدولي الذي يمر بمنبج
ليربط بين شرق سوريا وغربها.
على الضوء الاخضر. العملية
العسكرية التركية قاب قوسين او
وكذلك هو الموقف الروسي. وبين
تجاهل امريكي وروسي. ها هي سوريا
مطالبها لتمرير عملية تركية شمال
سوريا ولن تقبل موسكو باي تدخل
غواصة نووية في المحيط الهندي
وبحسب اعلام غربية فهذا الاعلان
اكبر شريك تجاري لالمانيا في
مجال السلع. ووصلت التجارة
امريكا ابرز الموردين للمغرب.
ياتي ذلك مواكبة لحركة ووتيرة
ادنى وواشنطن وموسكو ما من
معترض. فها هي روسيا تطرح
معلومات استخبارية سرية بالاضافة
الى توفير الجزء البحري والرادع
القوات الامريكية والكردية ضد
داعش في سوريا. فماذا عن بقية
تركي في سوريا الا بتلبية
مطالبها على في طريق الانفور
على هذه العملية ايضا لكنها فقط
تحذر تركيا من تعطيل عمليات
روسيا تريد ضمانة فتحه وان يكون
امنا. من جهتها امريكا لا تعترض
التسليح المتسارعة للجزائر
الجارة الشرقية للمملكة المغرب
منافسيهم في العالم. الامريكان
والذين يفاوضون بكين بقدم والقدم
ولكن الجزائر في الفترات الاخيرة
تنفق بشكل سخي ومرعب تجاه الجانب
الغربية عن مفاوضات مغربية مع
الصين لاقتناء اسلحة جديدة ويسعى
والصين قد تجعل برلين عرضة للضغط
الدبلوماسي من بكين في السنوات
المغرب لتعزيز قدراته العسكرية
وتنويع الموردين بعد ان كانت
مع التنين الصيني او رفض التطور
الصيني ولكن بشكل سري. فها هي
مشروعة لتمويل برامج الاسلحة
النووية والصاروخية لبيونج يانج.
المستشار الالماني على هذه
التسريبات? حيث تعد الصين حاليا
المسربة من ان العلاقات
الاقتصادية الوثيقة المانيا
الكراهية والصراعات العرقية حسب
وصفه. لعبة الصين المفضلة.
البعبع الصيني يكبر شيئا فشيئا
ودول الغرب لا تملك شيئا التحالف
المانيا تسعى للتعاون مع الصين
مؤخرا سياسيا واقتصاديا لتسقط
الثنائية بينهما الى مائتين وستة
وخمسين مليار دولار في عام الفين
زيادة التوتر مع بكين وخصوصا على
الصعيد الاقتصادي وحذرت الوثيقة
طلب منه اعادة المانيا النظر في
موقفها تجاه الوضع باوكرانيا.
منها سهوا وثيقة مسربة الى
الاعلام الغربي ان برلين تتوقع
بدقة واوكرانيا هي الهدف الاول
للمنظومة بحسب التقارير لكن لم
عن اسقاط مقاتلتين اوكرانيتين من
طرازي تسعة وعشرين وسوخوي خمسة
الاوكراني ان روسيا تستخدم الان
صواريخ ذات قدرة برؤوس حربية غير
خلفية بسبب كثافة القصف
الاوكراني لتعلن الدفاع الروسي
ان القوات الروسية شنت سبعا
وعشرين غارة جوية وقصفت باربعة
بعد عداء مرير على مدى اكثر من
عقد منذ اندلاع الحرب الاهلية
وعشرين. فيما اعلن حرس الحدود
البلاروسية اكتشاف مسيرة
اوكرانيا امر لا مفر منه. لكن ما
الذي يخطط له الالمان يا ترى?
الرئيس الشيشاني رمضان ويرد على
مزاعم بابا الفاتيكان حول قسوة
هي نظرية الصواريخ الجائعة. ولكن
على الارض اعلن الجيش الاوكراني
تقاوم جهود الوساطة الروسية لعقد
قمة مع الرئيس التركي اردوغان
ولفت بوتين نظر شولدز الى النهج
المدمر للغرب الذي يمد كييف
يتعين عليه ان يستخدم خطابا اكثر
سلمية وان ينأى بنفسه عن غرس
الوحدات الشيشانية مع الاسرى
مؤكدا ان بابا الفاتيكان كان
ومن الموقف الالماني نعود الى
الحرب الاوكرانية حيث كشفت
اكدت قوات روسيا نقلت بعض قواتها
في خرسون وزبروجيا الى خطوط
اوكرانية على عمق مائة متر
واسقاطها داخل اراضيهم. ليخرج
ناجحة لمنظومة صواريخ جديدة
والهدف كالعادة واصابة الاهداف
بالاسلحة. واضاف بوتين ان ضرب
البنية التحتية للطاقة في
واشنطن بوست الامريكية ان
البنتاجون وضع خطة جديدة بالقوات
اراضيها وفق رويترز المستشار
الالماني اولف شولدز يتصل
الاوكرانية بشكل اكثر فعالية
بينما الدفاع الروسية تجري تجربة
حال انخفاض الاسعار. لكن يبدو ان
لالمانيا رأيا اخر فبعد نفي
برلين اجراء محادثات مع كييف
بشأن نقل منظومات باتريوت الى
واربعين صاروخا البنية التحتية
في خرسون جنوبي البلاد. بينما
يتم الاعلان عن اسم ونوع هذه
المنظومة. في المقابل قال الجيش
غريب من الامريكان وهم من كانوا
يسعون سرا للتفاوض مع موسكو يا
الروسي سيرجي لافروف ان حلفا
الناتو ينشر قواته ومنشآته
والناتو بالفشل. اما الاتحاد
الاوروبي عندما لم يستطع التغلب
على روسيا بدعم اوكرانيا لم يجد
الا العقوبات كملاذ اخير لمواجهة
روسيا من دون مشاركة اوكرانية
وانها مستمرة في دعم كييف. تصريح
للبرميل مع الية تعديل لابقاء
السعر ادنى من مستوى السوق في
تطبيق حد اقصى لسعر النفط الروسي
المنقول بحرا بستين دولارا
الخارجية البريطاني جيمس
كليفيللي مصرحا ان بوتين قد
القومي الامريكي لا علامات لرغبة
بوتين بانهاء الحرب في اوكرانيا.
الروس. وها هي دول الاتحاد اخيرا
وبعد طول انتظار وبعد سحب بولندا
المفاوضات لحل الازمة
الاوكرانية. ليرد وزير الخارجية
اعتراضها توصلت حكومات الاتحاد
الاوروبي الى اتفاق مبدئي على
موسكو بمفردنا. وسنكون في مأزق
بدون الولايات المتحدة
للعجب. لكن الكرملين يقول ان
محاولات التفاوض مع واشنطن
بينما قالت الخارجية الامريكية
ان الولايات المتحدة لن تفاوض
يستغل محادثات السلام لاعادة
تجهيز جيشه قبل شن هجوم اخر وفق
صحيفة ياتي ذلك في ظل دعوات
غربية لروسيا للعودة الى طاولة
علني للروس. هناك قال جون كيربي
منسق الاتصالات في مجلس الامن
الامريكية. فهل امريكا هي من
تحمي اوروبا حقا ليخرج وزير
الحيوية بالقرب من الحدود
الروسية وهذا يعتبر عداوة بشكل
بالرئيس الروسي بوتين ويطلب منه
سحب قواته من اوكرانيا لكن بوتين
متفجرة بغرض استنزاف قدرات
الدفاعات الجوية الاوكرانية. نعم
تلفظ انفاسها الاخيرة. ليس على
الاوروبيين حرج. فالحرب الطويلة
سيرد المجنون. وامريكا وروسيا
تفتحان لتركيا في سوريا. اوروبا
اعقاب حرب اوكرانيا بصراحة لسنا
اقوياء بما يكفي للوقوف في وجه
تعري الدول ذات الغطاء الكاذب.
وها هم الاوروبيون يعلنونها
والتي قالت انه يجب تقديم تقييم
صادق للغاية لقدرات اوروبا في
المسربة تقول عكس ذلك وامريكا
تكشف عن سلاحها السري الذي يظهر
طائرة مسيرة في اراضيها. برلين
تتقرب من الصين لكن الوثائق
ترهق الدفاعات الاوكرانية
وبلاروسيا تعلن عن اسقاط اول
بانفسهم. وعلى لسان رئيسة
الوزراء الفنلندية سانا مارين
بالقرب من الصين. وواشنطن وسيول
تعاقبان كوريا الشمالية فكيف
يجري يا ترى? قديروف يرد على
بابا الفاتيكان بوتين الجائعة
موسكو بمفردها بينما الاتحاد
الاوروبي يتخذ اجراءات خبيثة
امريكا وفنلندا تقول اوروبا ليست
قوية بما يكفي للوقوف في وجه
تثير جنون الروس. وبوتين يرد
بالتفاوض مع المانيا. فما الذي
عن حرب عالمية ثالثة وهذا ليس
ضعفا منا. اتفهمون? هكذا قالتا
لو اهتمت اوروبا نفسها بدلا عن
الوقوف خلف العباءة الامريكية.